[Music]
it's happened to all of us you're in
your bed asleep with a loud scary noise
suddenly rips you out of your slumber
causing you to sit bolt upright in your
bed
hi I'm TVs Andy Richter being scared of
weight can be very upsetting and it can
leave you feeling awful for hours but
it's also one hell of an ab workout
what's happening when you sleep your
muscles relax and soften making you seem
lazy and gross but when something
terrifying interrupts that sleep your
stomach muscles engage in a way that you
could never duplicate at one of those
so-called gyms and that's where Andy
Richter's Dreamtime abdominal is Eider
comes in it's the only workout system
that gets you toned while you sleep
that's time you've just been wasting
stupid here's how it works
you go to sleep as you always would and
when the abdominal is ater senses that
you've reached your most relaxed state
it goes to work helping you get ripped
and the anomaly's aiders randomized
workouts make sure that you or your abs
never get complacent it's just that
simple
all we ask is that you give the
Dreamtime abdominal or riser 64 weeks of
nighttime workouts and if you don't
start to see results you're probably
doing something wrong oh and another
thing I'm sure a lot of you out there
saying hey Andy you know you could stand
to lose a few pounds where do you get
off selling workout equipment and to
that I'd say buthow don't you
for the deaf or hard-of-hearing try the
new hands on a dominant whatever so call
now dammit
[Applause]
you